So tell me about your book you want,
one of the things that was surprising that I had heard was you or your
experience with concussions now. Um, tell me about that.
So when I've had concussions in that flip,
I was talking about 1998 day tone. I got a concussion from that crash. Uh,
I'd had concussions throughout my career at many different points and didn't
think anything of them. I thought when you, you know, when you got a concussion,
you joked about it with your buddies about how it made you feel and you just
rested until it was gone and you race through it.
Uh, and eventually it go away and you were fine. You know,
it was just something that would go away. And you never thought anything about,
you never thought about seeing a doctor.
You never thought about getting treatment.
You didn't know there was even treatment available for a concussion.
You just thought it was something like a bruise, you know.
So this is going on throughout my whole career. I was racing it. Uh,
I was testing it Kansas, uh,
motor Speedway in 2012 blue right front tire hit the wall at 185 miles an hour
and it screwed me up.
And so that was a really not, you know,
that wasn't a typical crash,
not something that drivers deal with usually in their career.
This was something that was unique to me, uh,
and it was just a terrible impact at a bad angle, at a very,
very fast rate of speed.
And I got out of the car and I knew something was wrong with me and I couldn't,
you know, I couldn't, I felt, you know,
just like I'd been hitting the head with a bat, uh,
shocked and shell-shocked in a way or just couldn't, I couldn't,
uh, shake it off. You know,
you just kind of wanted to shake your head and get it out,
whatever it was and you couldn't. Um, that's the way I failed. Immediately.
Immediately after that crash, we went,
our tests was done cause the car was killed.
So we went over to this place to get some lunch and we're sitting there and I
started getting sick, nauseous before we ever, you know, I wouldn't even, uh,
we just ordered it. We just sat down and I started, I'm sitting with my team,
all my guys, and I'm, uh, starting to, I think I'm,
I'm throw up right there in front of him and I'm getting nervous and I don't,
I haven't said to them that I feel this way, you know,
so I don't want to tell them I feel this way. Um, but my crew chief,
Steve ATAR is like my brother. Um, as like Steve, I, uh,
am getting sick and something's wrong with me.
I don't know what's wrong with me,
but I got to get out of this room is a business lunch hour.
It's full of full of people, noises, talking, chatter, shit going on.
And I gotta get the hell out of there. Um,
and as I was getting up to leave my wife come walking in, they were,
she was coming to get me,
we were going to Washington Redskins Monday night game and uh,
sitting on her box with Dan Snyder and whoever else is.
So we had them plans to go. I said, Amy,
I'm gonna go lay down in the car. I just got to lay down the car for a minute.
And I laid down all the way in the car all the way to the airport. I'm thinking,
this is, this is bad, this is worse than I've ever failed anything.
But hopefully it's going to go away. And so we'd get the game we get,
we went into the Redskins game, we watched the game, uh,
did that whole thing.
And I went about four weeks of feeling bad and sick for about four weeks and it
finally went away. And I was,
I knew that was unusual for it to be that long,
but in my mind I wasn't thinking doctor. I wouldn't think in treatment.
I wouldn't think in anything like that.
It ain't crossed my mind to tell anybody here that I really needed. I thought,
you know, I thought that I had been dishonest and not,
uh, you know, I hadn't,
I hadn't been honest with everybody about the way I was feeling,
but I didn't never think that it was going to cost me anything. So I thought,
all right, I'm feeling better. I'm good. Go to this race.
I've been racing the whole time. Right. Finally, four weeks later I'm great.
I go to another race, I'm racing, I crashed and it all came right back,
like as bad as it was, if not worse.
And that's when I said I got to go to the doctor. This is bad. I can't,
you know, I can't even, you know, I can't keep crashing like this.
Just putting these concussions so close together is a bad deal is dangerous.
And my, I couldn't bite my tongue,
like my attitude and my emotions and shit was out of whack.
Like I couldn't control my anger and I was like, anybody would be,
anybody say something I didn't like. I'm like, you know,
I want to tell them to fuck off. You know? And that was just not like me.
I couldn't, I couldn't like keep myself calm and, uh,
everything that I heard like made me angry. It was the craziest thing.
Even people just talking about stuff, but just get under my skin. I'm like,
uh, real impatient. Um,
and there was some new symptoms, but I finally, uh, I went to the doctor and,
and uh, got to, I went to this neurosurgeon, Charlotte,
Dr. Petty. He's like, I want you to meet this guy in Pittsburgh.
His name's Mickey Collins.
He works with the Pittsburgh Steelers and the penguins. And, uh,
I'm like, all right. I go up there and I'm thinking,
I'm going to meet this guy that works,
works with the penguins in the Steelers and he sees, you know, players,
but he's a, he's a doctor that sees anybody and everybody,
like there's kids in there, you know, that got hurt playing on the playground.
There's workers, uh, con, you know, uh, carpenters, Housewives,
everybody's in that damn waiting room to see this man.
He sees about 25 people a day. And, um,
he's an expert on head injuries and he's got, you know, he's just,
he's on the cutting edge of whatever the hell the new shit is. He knows,
and he's, you know, his team and his people are investigating it.
And so there, uh, he fixed me. So I go there and I'm like,
this is what happened. This is how it happened. I crashed. I hit it.
I didn't tell anybody about it. I was sick for four weeks. I got better.
I crashed in this race and I feel sick again. And he was like, well,
these are two different injuries of two different parts of your brain.
The first injury you bruised, uh, right front edge of your brain. Uh,
when you hit the wall, he said this, the second crash,
you twisted the base of your brain and injured some things in the back of your
brain and that's why you're having the emotion or different things like that.
So, uh, but he went deeper into it than that. He was like, you know,
we did all these, uh, tests and, um,
visual tests and all kinds of stuff for, for, and I'd go back to,
I mean, we did this thing. We did,
I went through the gamut for a whole day of doing tests and then I went back
every, uh, week, uh, before I, you know,
and in two weeks I was back racing again. I was clear. And, uh, so he,
he took an injury that I hid and took four weeks to heal and healed it in two
weeks. What did he do to heal it? Um, he gave me,
I never took any medication on this particular, uh, issue.
He gave me a home exercises and I exercises. There was a,
I had problems with focusing and making my eyes work, tracking your knowledge.
It's like a bird flying across the sky or anything like that. I couldn't,
my eyes couldn't stay on it.
If I looked at you and my eyes would bounce off of you. Um,
and they just wouldn't stay, you know, if you said, Hey man,
we'll take a picture and you held up a camera.
And I tried to look at the lens and smile,
my eyes would wanna jump off of that object. They would want.
They didn't want to look at what I wanted them to look at and track anything
going anywhere. And this is the cause of that. Um,
the, the brain has the ocular stuff.
Uh,
I mean you can have injury to that part of your brain or you can have an injury
to the vestibular part of your brain that,
that of that may like if you had bad balance,
then that your eyes and your balance work together.
And so if you have a vestibular issues that can create ocular issues and um,
that can create, um, that, that can affect your, uh,
anxiety and depression and things like that. So all of these,
you can have an injury to one part of your brain that affects four other areas.
And so, and we talk about that in the book. Mickey comes into the book and,
um, I'll talk, you know, I'll say this is what I was feeling.
This is what I did. And Mickey, you will come in behind me and say,
this is the medical science behind that and this is how we treated it and why.
But I would have an injury to one singular area of my brain,
but I would have four different symptoms affecting four different parts of my
brain for different senses. And um, you know,
he would have to hone in on the one that was broken and then know to fix it.
And when he started fixing it,
all the other ones would start communicating together.
The brain would start working in balance and visual and all those things would
start to work again in anxiety and all those things, you know,
begin to come back in tune. No. When you said he fixed it,
like what is he doing? Uh, he, well,
so he gave me physical exercises to do.
I had some balance issues. Basically if I was, if I turned my head,
uh, or looked up and down, I would get dizzy and sick.
Like my stomach would turn if I turned my head left a ride.
If I looked up and down, just sitting there,
like the best thing for me was just sit on the couch and not move.
And so like literally not move and I felt fine then.
But if I moved an inch man, it was like Mike, it'd make you stomach nauseous.
And so I did a lot of motion.
I did a lot of exercises that created a ton of motion with my head.
I'm lifting heavy balls up and passing them over my shoulder this way or that
way, taking a ball and turning around and hit it this way,
taking the ball and turn around and hit that. Just doing that for,
for hours and hours and hours. And so I would train basically,
uh, I was training myself to, to balance again, you know, training my training,
my body to balance itself again.
And as in my,
if I couldn't see a horizon or a flat surface, uh,
I couldn't tell which way was up. And yeah, it was so bad. And,
um, the visual stuff, there was these a,
I had a string with these balls on it and I would hold the string on my nose and
hold it out here and I had to look at all those balls and it would, my ma,
my eyes are focusing just all it's doing is really just making my eyes change,
focus from one to the next to the next and back on to the next, next and back.
And there was this ad chart on the wall and it had all these letters and all
these numbers on it. And I had to, uh,
I had to look at that chart and turn my head back and forth this way,
but look at that eye chart and count and count, uh,
dude from a to Z, but backwards do the alphabet.
So I'd have to look for the letters. Where's the, you know,
and go backwards or one, one to 20, you know. Oh, why are you shaking your head?
Two, three, yeah. And standing up and walking backwards and walking forward.
And what is this doing to your mind? Like, how do, how does this fix your mind?
What is the mr process? You know, I don't know what the real,
I don't know what it's the,
I've had the problem with me was my system.
So my ability to understand, balance and understand horizons.
And so I was putting my mind in a perplex,
uh,
in a complex environment or making my mind do complex things that you don't do
every day and it's just firing and it's, yeah,
it's kind of like stretching this muscle, you know, it's like,
it's like they used to say when you would get hurt to go into a dark room and
hide and, or you know, no, no electronics, no TV,
just sit in a dark room and wait. And what they're,
what they believe today is that exposure is what helps pushing yourself into
these complex environments and doing things that are really challenging for
yourself. Even doing that,
if I put you in front of that ad chart and made you turn your head back and
forth and walk, walking two steps forward, two steps back and doing it would be,
it'd been difficult for you. Um, uh, so,
but for an injured person it's super difficult. It has to be really challenging.
Um, but it just sort of tunes the mind or to retrains the brain to do balance to
balance it retrains the eyes to,
to track on objects and to lock on objects and stay on them.
And what's crazy is it sounds like physical rehab, if you had a knee injury,
there's a physical yes, there's a lot of physical rehab to it.
There's a ton of it.
And don't think about that when it comes to the mind though.
I'm actually think of the mind is like something that needs to be healed with
medicine. Yeah, I agree. Um,
all the probably 85% of the work that I did was physical therapy.
Does your diet or anything like that?
Cause they say inflammatory causing [inaudible]
foods. Are inflammation causing foods? I did not. I did not change.
I drank strictly drank water. I didn't drink anything other than water.
And uh,
I incorporated bananas and things like that into my diet that I never ate before
it and cause of potassium.
What effect does potassium have on in recovery?
I just hear that it's good for your brain. It's good for your brain is hurt.
Yeah, I did not, my doctor didn't say start eating this stuff, but it was just,
you know, you got, you get tidbits like when you go and get injured like that,
you're going to get people texting you and giving you the information here and
there and you kind of take what you want and go at, you know,
I don't know about that, but, um, did you ever mess with CBD at all? CBD?
You don't know what that is? No. No. Interesting. Um,
CBD is a non-psychoactive form of hemp and uh,
it's a radical inflammation fighter in a lot of people that have like some
pretty significant injuries to the brain.
A lot of fighters take it like right after fights. It used to be, um,
it's still questionable federally.
Like they're trying the,
there's some pushes to try to make it illegal just because of pharmaceutical
drug companies kind of putting pressure on them. Doesn't do anything.
In terms of like get you high or anything?
No, I've actually, I actually read a little bit about that, um,
just a couple of weeks ago because it, um, controls anxiety and,
and has helped a lot of people. That one of my biggest,
one of the problems that I faced just on a, you know,
on the regular everyday is, is where my anxiety is. Like,
is that because of being famous? I don't know.
I think it comes from like your childhood and just things that you experienced
in life. And what are you anxious about? Um,
just general social situation.
Yeah. Yeah. I mean I, I would avoid, I would, I've,
I've gotten a lot better. Like I go, I can't, I, I would avoid concerts.
Even if I love the band, I would, uh, just cause there's too many piano. Yeah.
Yeah. But does it 200 people that are gonna bother you? No. No. Um,
I don't think so. And I like being bothered.
I don't mind people coming up to me and saying, man, that's cool.
I know you are. I mean, that shit feels great,
but it was more about like,
am I going to be accepted? Is it? My scene is,
I don't know, man. I just always had a lot of anxiety over it.
Oh, okay. So anxiety about whether or not
you're going to fit in fit in. Yeah. Okay.
So you felt like an outsider when you're younger. Yeah. Yeah. So that anxiety,
I don't know, I still feel, um, I D I don't,
you know, so that shit goes away hard. Takes a long time for that to go away.
Yeah. Yeah. Like my wife, um, she, uh,
likes ashwagandha. You ever heard the around around? Yeah. So she,
she likes that and I take that every once in a while and I think that shit works
pretty good. Kind of keeps you calm and, yeah. Yeah. So,
but I've never tried to,
I've read about when I was reading about ashwagandha is when I read about that
stuff you're talking about,
I'll get you something. It'll help. CBD is amazing and you know what?
It's really good.
There's some muscle balms that work really good on sore joints and stuff.
I mean, but like, and nothing I've ever used before, better than anything.
CBD just gets right into the muscles. And just relaxes all the inflammation.
And the best part about it is it's 100% natural and no side effects.
There's nothing but in terms of like,
there's a bunch of different CBD oils you can take and you just,
they chilly out but they don't get you high or anything. You're not weirded out.
But they just just calm me down. Right.
And I wonder how much that calming down is because of inflammation.
Just reducing inflammation and just, it just, it seems to, your body has a,
your body knows what to do with it. He bought, he's like, Oh,
I know what this is. This is good. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I mean I got Ted NuGen into it. Really? Man, Ted Nugent, before he came on here,
he was telling me how he's on anti marijuana and this and that,
and we had this conversation about it, but makes people lazy. I'm like,
I don't think it does, man. I think people are just lazy. And I told him,
because I know he's got some serious knee problems,
had all these knee surgeries. He's, you know, he's a mad man.
He used to jump off the top of the fucking stage and land on the ground and blew
his meniscus out. Yeah.
I got him on the CBD balm now and now he texted me the other day. He said,
there's not a thing I've ever used. It's helped me like this before. Really?
Yeah. So now I'm having cases sent to him like every week. Yeah.
He loves the shit. I mean, he's, he wants to endorse it, which is hilarious.
Like the motor city madman, Ted Nugent, super anti marijuana, wants to enjoy,
so endorsed a cannabis product that's helped as Nick. Yeah. Yeah.
But it doesn't do anything to you psychologically.
It doesn't affect you calm me down. Yeah. That's what I read about it. Yeah.
Doesn't have that part of the part of the drug. My friend's son has,
um, it's a type of epilepsy, uh,
Brendan shop and he started giving his kid CBD oil and it stopped the epilepsy
in its tracks.
Yeah. I think I read where they are. Um,
it's been used for that for years. Yes. Yes. Yeah. To hail,
uh, for, um, God
seizures. Yes. Yeah. For seizures. Yeah.
It's just a radical inflammation, decrease her, just figures out a way.
It does it as some sort of interaction with your body where it just reduces
inflammation. But it's just like I said, it also calms people down,
alleviates anxiety and no side effects. That's the most important one.
Some people, it gives them a weird stomach. They don't like the way,
but I think they'd probably take it too much or maybe it's expired or something
like that. Yeah. I've never had those issues. But I'll get you something.
You should look into that too. Right? Yeah. So what else did they do with you?
Did you do any cryotherapy or anything like that that also would reduce
information?
No, no. Basically I went and, um, in this,
in 2012, we did may S basic, basic, uh,
physical therapy and eye therapy,
eye eye tests and different eye exercises.
Um, and in two weeks I was back in the race car raced for, that was
in 2012. I raced all the way to 2016. Two weeks.
You felt a hundred percent yeah. That's amazing.
So with all these crazy exercise you're doing,
when did you feel like it settled in? Like, wow, this is really working?
Uh, [inaudible]
pretty. I mean, if it was a two week period, it wasn't, you know,
it was a day or two I guess. You know what I mean? I can't even remember.
I can't remember that far back a day or two. Yeah. I mean,
I imagine it was feeling pretty good after a couple of days. I'd have to,
I don't know. I mean, I don't know if it affected me right away or,
but I know I was, by the time we had, I take an impact test,
which is basically kind of measures memory and things like that,
all kinds of different stuff. And my, um,
measurements had come back to my norm, you know, my basic, uh, uh,
you're, you know,
they kind of make you take the impact test beforehand so that gets your,
your blueprint of how you are and, uh, and then whenever you get injured,
you take it again and they'll line that up against, against that and say, okay,
yeah, you're deficient here. This is a problem.
Maybe it's not diagnosing a concussion,
but it's asking us to look in this area.
And so you have a baseline and then you have whatever the post, you know,
your injury or post-crash uh, baseline is. Um,
so I was matching all my normals on that impact test and that was kind of the
trigger for them to go, man, if you feel good, you look good here.
All the things you're saying that your back, you know. And uh,
I wanted to go race so I feel pretty good.
Is it a strange feeling knowing that you can't see what the damages like a brain
injury is a strange one, right? Because it's affecting everything in your body,
but you don't, you don't see it. Like if you have a broken arm,
you're looking at it, you know, it's in a cast that gets fixed. You know,
you're, you're aware of it. You're doing rehab on it,
you're looking at and while you're doing it, yeah.
There's something about the brain where it's all like you can kind of mind fuck
yourself and say, I think, I think I'm okay. Yeah. That's why. So in the,
in the book I talk about these notes,
I started taking after that crash in 2012 when I would wreck after that I would
get sick and I wouldn't tell anybody.
And so I started writing these notes in my, in a journal, in my phone.
And from 2013 all the way to 2016 I had this long journal of crashes and how I
felt and I would, uh,
crash on Sunday and I'd ride in the journal on Sunday night, Monday morning,
Monday at lunch, money at night, you know, every three times a day,
every day until whenever I felt good,
which was usually either Wednesday or Thursday of that week.
And I was writing these notes because I couldn't tell if I was getting better
than the brain injury or any type of head injury. I mean, if you said,
how's it feel Monday? And then you asked me again Tuesday, I'd be like,
I really don't fucking know man. It just, it's there.
I don't know if it's better, I just feels bad.
And so I would try to write is detailed as I could.
On a day on a Monday and then try to write as detailed as I could on Tuesday and
reread Monday and see, Hmm, is this better?
I can see in the comments or you know,
I can't really remember exactly what I was feeling Monday,
but in the comments it seems better and I would write these notes. Right.
And so I kept doing this and I thought I was treating myself and eventually it
caught up with me.
Like I had about a dozen concussions in a period of about two and a half years.
Wow.
And I got to where I couldn't walk and I called my owner and I was like,
man, I need to talk to ya can't race this weekend. I can't hardly walk.
And my balance is so bad that I can't get up off the couch without holding on to
something and walking across the room without grabbing stuff as I go.
And he was like, we got to go back to the doctor. What are you doing?
He was mad. He's like, you know, what do you fucking do?
And getting to the doctor, why aren't you at the doctor? And I was like,
you're right, I need to go to doctor. I mean,
a concussed person doesn't have good judgment and self-awareness, you know,
you're just, you're just in a brick and you're in a, it's like being hung over.
You have the worst hangover, you can't make decisions.
And so I went back to Pittsburgh,
saw Mickey again and I had to stay out the entire whole half of the year in 2016
to get better. It took me five months to get, well instead of two weeks. Wow.
And that time, um, I was on,
they put me on medication that would drop my anxiety levels so the anxiety
levels would stay down so that I could concentrate on, uh,
the injury and what medications? Um, I'd ha,
I don't know exactly the names, but um, it was, uh,
it was very,
very small doses and it would take about three weeks for it just to kind of kick
in. I'd have to take it for a while before it started working. Um,
but it just made me real chill and it made me not analyze myself every single
day when I got up. When I got up I wouldn't go, Hmm, is it still there?
Is it as bad as it was? Let me walk across the room and see how I feel.
Let me go do this and test this and try this and try this and try this all day
long and see how I feel.
It made me stop doing that cause I was driving myself crazy and um,
he gave me a lot more physical therapy, basketball movements,
anything that got my head moving. Um,
I do those exercises for about two weeks.
Some of them would stop triggering symptoms.
I'd go back to his place in Pittsburgh.
We'd go through about 30 more exercises and I'd take home about 15 that made the
symptoms trigger. And I do them for about two,
three weeks and some of them would stop working. I go back to him,
we'd go through more physical exercises to, you know,
kept doing that process over and over and over.
I took the medication for about a year and a half. Um,
and I had a lot of, they gave me this, uh,
computer program for my eyes and I was wearing these,
I would wear these three D glasses and uh, uh,
this computer program would try to take these three D objects and go to two D
and back to 3d in my eyes would literally try.
It would felt like it's trying to rip my eyes apart.
It hurt like physically hurt when this object would try to go from,
from uh, 3d to D and it was going very,
very slowly and it felt like it was trying to rip my eyes apart and imagine your
eyes are tethered together so when you look left, they both go there, right.
And they both go wherever you look, they go together like they're supposed to.
And mine didn't want to do that. Mine,
you couldn't physically see my eyes towed out or going the wrong way.
You couldn't see that. But when I tried to look over here,
they both didn't go to the same place.
And that was that action or that,
that computer program was strengthening that activity of my eyes,
trying to do something together and I would walk.
So if I,
I've got these Buffalo on my property and they're across the field, wait,
you know, 200, 300 yards out across the field,
out the back window of my living room. And if I walked across the floor,
every step I took would knock my eyes off of the,
like they're way out there and I could look at them. But if I took a step,
my eyes would shake and I couldn't, I'd have to find them again, you know?
And so that would, that computer program would strengthen my ability.
It's called gaze stabilization. It would make it to where when I walk, I don't,
you know, if I'm walking or bouncing across the room,
I'm S I can still look at you in the eyes and you know, like a normal person.
And if I, when I was in my, at my worst, I couldn't do that. And so, uh,
but that took a long time to fix. And, uh,
the book basically is me admitting, making those mistakes. Uh,
I should've went to him as soon as I got sick again the first time.
Instead of trying to document it myself and, and hide it and,
and manage it myself and trying to get to whatever the end of my career was,
whenever that moment was and retire,
thinking I was going to walk away without anybody ever knowing. Um,
and it, and I had to retire after that,
after that 2016 year of missing half a season and going through all that,
I didn't want to go through it again.
I had one more year on my contract in 2017 so I finished that season.
And that was that. Were you apprehensive while you're finishing that season?
Yeah, I didn't want to get hurt.
I didn't want to go back through that whole process again and go through that
rehab again. I didn't want to get sick again.
Me and my wife just got married on new year's of 2016 17.
So we are newlyweds. We're getting, she's pregnant. Uh,
we're going to have a baby. Um, you know,
I didn't want to go through any of that stuff sick.